en juillet 2014 maïwenn a passé deux
mois seul dans une minuscule chambre de
l'hôpital maisonneuve rosemont
elle et son grave cancer du sein il ya
cinq ans vous êtes ici jour pour jour
vous êtes une femme courageuse mais deux
mois en isolation
avez vous le temps qu'on n'a pas une
fois par les allemands
donc oui en fait ses chances de survie
étaient très faibles
mais la médecine de pointe la sauver un
don de cellules souches une greffe
réussie
aujourd'hui elle est en rémission si
j'avais le même classée no 25 ans je
serai pas là maintenant ma fille à la
peau de marc les avancées sur ce point
les chiffres ne mentent pas
depuis 1990 le taux global de survie des
patients est passé de 55% à 63% pour
certains cancers siro id testicules
prostate et pédiatrique
c'est carrément spectaculaire on voit
que le cancer est devenu une non plus
une maladie mortelle mais bien une
maladie chronique une maladie que l'on
peut traiter et que l'on peut même pour
des cancers difficile justement
retraités ces genres sur de très longues
périodes ce sont les progrès réalisés
dans le traitement des cancers du sein
qui retiennent le plus l'attention
lymphome ni et longues ou leucémie
l'espérance de vie est en hausse par
tous ces petits miracles ont les doigts
la médecine personnalisée
la médecine de précisions c'est une
médecine qui est basée sur une meilleure
compréhension de la biologie des tumeurs
et de la biologie des xix
donc finalement on récolte les fruits de
décines il recherche et selon docteur de
lille l'avenir est encore plus
prometteur quand republier 9e 4 6 ans
les statistiques vous allez voir que
cette tendance à l'amélioration des
traitements basés sur la biologie va
reprendre un plus grand effort encore
plus grand
mais pour madewell la science est déjà
rempli ses promesses
le 9 octobre 2009 50 et donc doc
si on revenait dans le temps sur mon lit
de mars c'est ce que je me dis souvent
j'étais sur mon lit de mort je peux
jamais espéré cinq ans plus tard etc et
vous parlez vous reparler aujourd'hui
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal